[Music]
hi everyone my name is Samir I'm a
gaming solution architect at koko cloud
today I will be introducing you open
match and open SUSE matchmaking firm
work based on kubernetes the Nishikawa
son from grinch will share about the
experience using open match in kik
flight a new 4v4 mobile game that just
released last month so before diving
into grange experience of open match
let's first take a look at what exactly
it is but to explain you how it was
founded I first need to explain the
challenges that many developers face
with matchmaking services match meeting
is one of the hardest unsolved problem
for online multiplayer games at a
fundamental level matchmaking takes
players connect to your games to match
them up and connect them to game servers
creating a good match is critical to
your game success and what constitute I
could match changes from game to game
you have to consider attributes like
skills level latency wait time and there
are all critical to your game in general
making a good matchmaking service for a
game is hard but its core to your game
design running this as a global scale
for your player population presents a
whole different set of challenges
architecting a matchmaking service that
can run at high scale reliably is very
hard and may not be an interesting
problem to solve for a game developer
this is exactly why open match was
created so open match is an open source
matchmaking framework co-founded with
unity it leverages grenade this to
provide flexibility scalability and
extensibility just to give you an
example of scale it can handle maybe you
remember the Halloween Doodle from 2018
that 44 multiplayer game you could play
from the google.com website yeah that
was using open match to match players
and it handled a concurrent peak of
500,000 players because with open match
you don't need to worry about the
scalability and reliability of the
underlying infrastructure you can focus
on building the core logic of your
matchmaker because I seen pictures worth
a thousand words let's take a look at
the high-level architecture of how an
online games will integrate with open
match on the left side you have a game
front-end with your core game logic that
calls into the matchmaking framework and
at the same time on the right side you
have a pool of servers that players can
be placed on that simultaneously calling
in the matchmaking logic open match sit
in the middle handling the players that
are available splitting them by skill
level latency etc and match them up with
servers that are available as a
developer you only care about developing
the match function which contains the
core logic of your matchmaker
the rest and right boxes are component
from your game that you need to
integrate with open match let's take a
closer look at those components in the
left and right boxes the game front-end
is the endpoint where your game clients
will connect to to avoid cheating you
don't want them to directly connect to
the open match front-end because only
your game front-end is capable of
verifying the data provided by the game
clans by accessing a database containing
players data so basically it's your game
front-end that creates matchmaking
requests also called tickets and open
match on the right side you find the
game backin also called director and the
dedicated game servers your game backend
is a key component in the matchmaker
since it triggers the match function
execution once open match finds matches
it will also handle the assignment of
game servers to the match players this
architecture is something you can then
reuse across
your games as you build multiple games
to have a better idea of how is the flow
of a match let's take a look at the life
of a match
step by step first step a player wants
to play against other players the game
client makes a request to your game
front end to find a match
it's the game front-end that actually
makes the requests to the open match
front end to find a match
every requests are stored in the state
store running on Redis as I mentioned in
the previous slide
it's the game back-end that triggers the
match function using the open match
back-end the game back and request for a
match the open match backend triggers
the matchmaking function that uses the
query component to quell Redis and find
candidates for a match once a fan a
match is found the open match back-end
will return it to the game back-end that
will then finalize the entire
matchmaking process by assigning a
dedicated game server to the match
players the last step of the life of a
match is the assignment it's the last
step where we assign a game server to
the match players for this the game back
and we are located a dedicated game
server by using solutions like a
goodness or any other custard custom
server management system once it gets
the allocated game server IP and port it
will reach out again to the open match
back-end to update it gets stored in the
state store with that information
finally once tickets have been updated
the game front-end will push that game
server details to players who will then
connect to the server and just start to
play and voila that's how open match
works in a nutshell hope this was clear
enough if you're building a small game
you might not be interested in a complex
highly scalable matchmaking framework
but you can still leverage open match to
write a simple matchmaking function that
will look like a single function in the
language of your choice plug that into
the framework and you have a fully
functional matchmaking service
without a lot of work but we're open
match really shines is if you have a
really large system with thousand or
millions of players that are all coming
at the same time and the player
population is segmented into different
groups and matched up very quickly so
you might be running hundreds of
concurrent matches on the player
population looking for the best match to
make your game work so now that you know
what's open match is let's listen to the
experience of the Japanese game studio
Grange using open match in their latest
mobile game kit flight hi my name is
Yasunori I'm an engineering manager at a
branch it will talk about why and how we
use open match in kick fight our
explains game called kick fight kick
fight is free flying
and a middle area battle action game for
smartphones for versus for the airtime
multiplayer game you control character
called Akiko trip characters with three
game modes available in more than 130
countries launched on February 13th 2020
[Music]
here kick fights much making
requirements the video on the left shows
the much making using open match use
Excel [ __ ] under game-mode and by
tapping the battle button much making
speaking kick fight will match two teams
of four with the following requirements
much users with similar prey skills
matching users without forint pre skills
will desert ring a one side much
minimize character overlaps in battles
each of characters has a low there are
four types attack support tank and speed
much banking is done so that the same
character or role does not solve suffer
as much as possible you can cancel
anytime before matchmaking is found the
progress is displayed in the air time
during much making there is for reasons
why we decided to use Obama's the first
one is because we wanted to make a
general purpose much making framework
because building up matchmaker for each
game is pricey building a
general-purpose much making with the
budget of a game is not possible as a
result each game had a different much
making implementation depending on the
type of matchmaking making a matchmaker
game with one game up can take anywhere
from six months to a year even in that
case there are many problems about
scaring in quick break the development
of matchmaking logic was about one or
two months ease and the trip took about
one months for version updates and load
test most importantly this
can be used to build faster using open
match in the future
secondary because we wanted you to focus
on the matchmaking logic in general
scalability is a major issue in much
making this problem was minimized
because open match is by design scalable
sad because we could found working MMF
samples at that time there wasn't much
documentation but there are some working
examples we did the source code and got
the help of Google Ads the last one is
because open match was used successfully
in the Harwin doodle in 2018 this is
kick for it objection except for
real-time game Saba everything is built
on TCP the central part is open much
creation and the addition of kids are
performed from the API Saba through crud
load balancer acquisition of assignment
is requested to open match we are
ingress and endpoints the default open
match uses various ports on gke we have
changed that to cross memory store as a
side note we used crud spanner as our
main database in keiki fight there are
three main components the API changes
the kicker and enhances the skill of a
character called a disk it is
implemented using PHP 7 and it uses
crawled memory store for ladies fall
session cache and crud spawner for
player data open matches version is
version 0.7 with some customization
added 800 spray as much making
and matchmaking function is also
implemented in PHP 7 dedicated game
server handles the real-time aspect of
bottles let me show you one two went
well with open match we are able to
focus on the development of the
matchmaking logic open much does the
communication part with a client and the
scale so we are able to concentrate on
matchmaking logic steering the system
based on the number of players we can
scale by increasing front-end and much
making function also easily modified
much making criterias since front-end
and much function are separated just
modify the logic same build and deploy
the images we can deploy without any
downtime the Saba management was
simplified thanks to the manager subsys
like GK and crowd memory store we use
Cloud endpoints to secure the access to
the open match front-end it was very
easy to use with GK because it was made
for kubernetes by default ladies in GK
is used but management is easier using
cloud memory store this helped reduce
operation cost assignment communication
is done via cloud endpoints originally
it should be done via our game server
front-end but handling streaming
connection in PHP is complex so we used
ingress and Crandall endpoints to handle
this part finally for monitoring open
much telemetry works seamlessly with tuk
driver
here few changes we face with our game
we launched a game using open match for
the first time in the world we use very
early versions from Bajan 0.3 of open
match back in version 2.3
there was not much documentation so
relays source codes with help from
Google's here are some tuning we have
done on much open match for fried
parallel processing by splitting
profiles a much profile is open matches
representation overmuch specification
for example processing is performed
empowering for each game mode we
adjusted the literal intervals if the
literal interval is too short the load
on the lady Saba will increase
increasing this interval can reduce the
load on the little Saba
we also adjusted the ladies teachers
longitude here will increase data volume
the shuttles of TTL the lowers a lot on
the lady Saba we use Shih Tzu instances
it is important to much in a short
period of time as it will not be able to
judge if the matchmaking queue
accumulates for that purpose very fast
processing is realized using shitty
instances for example the difference
between 1.0 seconds and 0.8 seconds will
make a big difference we reduce the
filter condition of profile the load on
increased according to the
multiplication of the learning profile
and filter
so we changed to minimum filter
conscience we backported from version
0.8
execution from back end to function was
not balanced in addition we performed
load tests of communication part using
locust finally let's look back at the
game roads we are able to handle the
load at the time of launch frothy during
our load test we measure open match
could handle at least 250 entries per
second
we had no incident caused by open math
so far we developed our own solution to
clean the increasing release data open
much version 0.10 will include this
week's in conclusion we are very
satisfied with open much we could access
the game development speed and we could
provide a very fast yet scalable
matchmaking service to our players we
plant to the u s-- open match for our
next games and even expanded to other
game studios in our group roster e if
you are interested in open match I
recommend it to looking at the website
open match dot tab where you can find a
great documentation and many examples to
get studies I can't wait to see what you
can come up with open match in you again
[Music]